one mdb is one of the biggest
frauds financial frauds in history we
woke up one morning in july 2015 to
realize that almost 700 million
had gone into the prime minister's
account the disappearance of billions of
dollars from malaysia's state fund is
one of the biggest financial scandals
not just in malaysia but around the
world of the 8 billion
that 1mdb raised via bond sales it's
alleged more than half
was stolen that's different from a stock
fraud or pumping up a stock
and then cashing out on your options
this is actual theft of money
one mdb in malaysia had been actually
some kind of a piggy bank for various
you know players the stolen money went
to buy a private jet
luxury real estate artworks by picasso
and monet as well as jewelry
for mr najib's wife up to 300 000
taking to the streets calling for
najib's hit
they are fed up with a government that
they believe is chronically corrupt
the projects that were developed by 1mdb
were sold as
development projects it would be benefit
of everyone but it was later
realized that you know it cost the
country probably more than it helped
this was a cash grab by a handful of
people who put themselves in the
position
to make themselves rich it was a
betrayal of the people on a grand scheme
i arrived at the 1mdb expose
through a sort of process of having
started to report
on the consequences of malaysian
corruption
on the ground that was the destruction
of the borneo rainforest
as i looked into it was plainly caused
by
political corruption there was no
logical or sensible reason
if you were governing the country for
the benefit of the democratic
electorate that you would just rip out a
jungle
that was done for pure profit for a
handful of decision makers
so i started looking at that story
because it was an enormous story with
huge global ramifications british
journalist claire castle brown grew up
in the malaysian states of sarawak
in 2010 she set up the sarawak report to
expose corruption in the country of her
birth
i found that i could reach the public in
malaysia
and get through what had been a very
oppressive media
environment to actually get information
to
ordinary people in malaysia about how
their country was being run
one mdb was presented by nigebras at the
new prime minister
as a wonderful opportunity he was going
to raise huge sums of money for this
so-called sovereign wealth fund
to invest he was also the finance
minister of course as well as the prime
minister so he would be investing the
money
in all sorts of money making activities
that would then be you know
beneficial to to malaysians in need of
development
but all that money was disappearing
there was no accountability
and by the time i looked at it we're
talking about 2014
there had been five years of massive
fundraising and then total black hole as
far as where that money had gone
i think we were talking about an 11
billion dollar
deficit unaccounted deficit by 2014.
there were certain characters associated
with the fund who were also dabbling in
my area of interest which was the
rainforest state of sarawak
particularly a young chinese adviser to
the fund and to the prime minister
named joe lowe jo low in particular had
been gaining an international reputation
for himself
as a massive spender catching the
headlines in
new york las vegas and indeed hollywood
he was creating a stir he was the
highest spender in
in all the top nightclubs and yet had no
um
explanation really for his wealth as a
lot of you in this room know
i like to plan my evenings and make sure
that i always go to the best parties
so those of us who are looking at this
from malaysia were wondering whether his
advisory role
at 1mdb where all these billions were
not being accounted for
might be connected to this acquisition
of extraordinary wealth by a 26 year old
who'd come from nowhere
i first got my teeth into this story
with the launch of a
major 100 million dollar hollywood movie
wolf of wall street which is all about a
bunch of crooks who's stolen money and
we're spending it
the real question is this was all this
legal absolutely not
which is exactly what the uh the funders
of the movie were doing of course
through one mdb
because i was able to join some dots and
i realized that the malaysian money
funding this
film more than likely came from this
fund because
uh the producer of the movie was none
other than the son of the malaysian
prime minister who was in control of the
fund that was losing all this money
wow this is an incredible incredible
honor frieza aziz and jolo even got a
shout out
at the golden globes joey rizz and joe
thank you for being uh
not only collaborators but taking a risk
on on this movie
[Music]
[Applause]
so the one mdp scandal could not have
happened
um on just a localized basis
it was necessary for the the ringleader
the alleged
you know an accused ringleader of this
jolo to find accomplices
and people that he could deal with in
other countries around the world
as you look back and unwind the
development of
one mdb and who the early partners were
there was clearly
a certain amount of collusion from
interested parties in saudi arabia
and the united arab emirates the petra
saudi data which was passed to me by
a whistleblower former director of the
company it showed
the internal workings behind the
original setting up of the first joint
venture of 1mdb
with this saudi shell company
that was purporting to be an oil company
right at the start of of this extended
scandal
you see the emails which show a bunch of
young men
agreeing to pull off this scam but at
the end of the letter they said of
course we would also be willing to act
as a front
if that would be useful for some of your
operations so it was all there
along with the the data that showed the
transfers of money
the initial deal the petra saudi bond
deal and joint venture
siphoned nearly 2 billion out of the
fund that was the first information i
got hard data on
jolo has been charged in the united
states with being
basically the ring leader of this fraud
the guy who orchestrated it
even though he had no title within 1mdb
i've been asked whether or not he's like
a brilliant guy
or a you know criminal genius i don't
think so it's more
he's financially very sophisticated he
understood
according to the charging documents in
the u.s how do you set up shell
companies and how to hide the identity
of certain entities
and to create that first level of
obfuscations
people like jolo and some other you know
individuals
were able to construct an elaborate set
of deceptions
and shell companies that sounded just
like real companies
in order to you know divert the money
launder it
cover it up and make it appear as though
everything was fine
jolo was very smart about covering his
tracks one of the first things he did
right when one mdb was getting up and
running in 2009
joelo basically established an account
at a bank or a company in the seychelles
called goodstar
after you know the deal was struck to
invest in this joint venture with sign
off from the 1mdb board
a mysterious you know loan obligation
appears that 700 million
you know of the first 1 billion dollars
committed to this venture
is going to go to pay back a loan from
petra saudi the us government discovered
that there was no such loan
but under the excuse that a 700 million
loan had to be paid immediately out of
the first billion dollars
a transfer took place from one mdp's
primary bank
two it was said it was described it was
going to go to petra saudi but in fact
it went to
this small shell company called goodstar
and the ownership was hidden
it was uh like one share a bearer bond
uh that was owned by jolo but none of
that was obvious
so he was smart enough to disguise that
first transaction
and have a cover story that good star
was actually the name of the venture
perhaps the most famous example of
jolo's ability to disguise
hide or obscure the source or the the
destination of the funds was an outfit
that
he you know one of his colleagues came
up with called blackstone
asia real estate which sounds remarkably
like a you know
very successful u.s you know private
equity firm blackstone
but it has nothing to do with the real
blackstone it was clearly it was just a
shell company
uh that used the name blackstone to sort
of give it you know a level of
credibility
you know this happened over and over
again coming up with
you know bogus names that sounded good
or that sounded like or might be similar
to
so that uh the banks who were you know
unknowingly
you know basically passing along money
from one company to another
wouldn't it wouldn't raise any obvious
red flags today
the department of justice has filed a
civil complaint
seeking to forfeit and recover more than
one billion dollars in assets
associated with an international
conspiracy to launder funds
stolen from one malaysia development
broad or one
mdb what makes this such a potent and
devastatingly successful theft if you
will
is basically he had the support of the
government of malaysia
in the form of the prime minister if
somebody has trust the law then
you know they have to face the music
the money spread around the world and a
great deal of it
was laundered in the u.s you can see
this extraordinary
constellation of luxury properties and
homes
in beverly hills in new york and in
london
famous pieces of art luxury boats
gambling sprees in las vegas it's one
thing for us to care about
money being looted from people in
countries around the world
but also when that money's coming to the
us and coursing through our system
all this dirty money is a major cause of
concern
as pressure mounted on the malaysian
prime minister najibra zak
he was ousted from power in may 2018.
the new prime minister mahetti mohammed
wins partly on a platform that calls for
an investigation
into the missing billions from 1mdb
there are many charges
that can be prepared against those
involved
soon after the election police raid
properties linked to mr najeeb and his
wife rosma mansour
and sees hundreds of boxes of luxury
goods we have sealed the bags but we
know they contain money
and we know they contain jewelry police
carted away 284 boxes containing luxury
handbags
and 72 bags stuffed with cash and
jewelry
the hall which authorities later value
at 273 million dollars
includes 567 handbags 423 watches
234 pairs of sunglasses and 14 tiaras
in amongst the trinkets was 29 million
dollars in cash
the couple maintained the luxury goods
were gifts and that the cash
was political donations the country and
the people suffer
and we must get hold of every cent
that has been taken out from the country
after facing trial for just some of the
charges najib razak has been sentenced
to 12 years in prison
and fined 50 million dollars he's
appealing the decision
what do you say to those who say that
you've acted dishonestly about the funds
you know you've been called all sorts of
things including a thief
what what's your response to that
there's no evidence of that
i mean you cannot just you know accuse
somebody but you have admitted that the
funds did end up in your accounts even
though it was a donation from the saudi
government
yeah it's been it's been part it's been
cleared there's been no wrongdoing
there is an appeal process in malaysia
which is extremely lenient
towards the rich and powerful and which
continues for years
and so therefore najib continues to walk
free
and he indeed continues to vote in
parliament
while his case is under appeal the 1mdb
case
is far from over it's spread to all
corners of the globe
jolo is a fugitive and there's plenty of
money still missing
not to mention the amount malaysia is
paying an interest on those original
shady bond deals more than 11 billion
dollars of debt
wrecked up in five years a lot of people
you know when you talk about it you know
their eyes just
glaze over it's numbers that they were
talking about hundreds of millions
billions of dollars
financial concepts that not all people
are familiar with
ultimately when this type of thing
happens the people who benefit
are just that that cream at the top the
kleptocrats
and the people who lose uh the people
who remain impoverished
are the people who were like nominally
intended to benefit from the development
of the
the oil wells or the mining concession
or whatever
the scandal has revealed just how easily
money laundering can take place
and how far corruption can reach the
complicity of the global financial
system
continues to be exposed
the department filed criminal charges in
new york against the goldman sachs group
and its malaysian subsidiary charging
each with conspiracy to violate
the anti-bribery provisions of the
foreign corrupt
practices act malaysian goldman agreed
on a settlement of 3.9
billion dollars financial scandal after
financial scandal involving big banks
to be able to divert that much money
from basically a government-sponsored
enterprise
and then use a network of global banks
is just astounding
[Music]
do
you